[Music]
5 Open 52 nd
I left on my own It's
certainly cool, but
Rossitsu 5
Well, that's not the case.
It's not who
it is, it's a mando of less than 7 nights, isn't it?
You're wearing someone else's mask and you're always doing bad things--
and what's that
?
Don't be resolute
I'm going to put my hand on the voodoo door brain It's okay so stay still
oops
2 Arthur
is cute now I lent it to you
so please be quiet at home a
[music]
Aso's big stall 2  I'm going to take a selfie with people Tokidridgely
Yes, Nagoya Port Chikko
Yurine's costume is a bit of a failure
Yurine doesn't have breasts, so I shouldn't have made a design that emphasizes my breasts, because I can't emphasize them.
Music] It's
kind of empty, but it's not
cool.